last weekend doublelift was temporarily
banned from co-streaming the lcs he said
something that riot really didn't like
and they issued him his second strike as
an official co-streamer let's talk about
what he said and all the drama that's
come since
[Music]
well would you look at the time it's
double lift time again if you enjoy
these kinds of videos then make sure you
leave a like and also subscribe to the
channel we are so close to two million
subs now i can almost smell it smells
like um warm chocolate now if you know
doublelift you'll know he's made a
couple of headlines since parting ways
with tsm's league team last year and
retiring as a pro the streamer called
out his former boss and tsm owner reggie
as a bully who made players cry sparking
a riot investigation which condemned
reggie's behavior towards tsm staff and
left him with a two-year probation but
since the release of that report last
week doublelift himself has got into
some hot water with riot he recently
took part in the ultimate crown event
set up by mr beast where mr beast and
ninja faced off in a league of legends
tournament featuring some massive
streamers and former pro players
doublelift 1v2 the last man standing on
his team
beautiful hook on the side of ludwig and
it actually did turn out a little bit
okay for the team doublelift placing
himself in the middle between team beast
and dragon it looks like miss gets going
in they actually want to fight this
doublelift he steps up and miscarried
punishes now although doublelift seemed
to have lots of fun at the event he
later talked about one person in
particular who wasn't there bjergsen
they have a lot in common they're both
the only serious contenders for the
all-time goat of the lcs they're good
friends former tsm teammates and they
both retired at one point the only
difference is that bjergsen later
returned to pro play and now that he's
back as a pro player bjergsen has to
play by riot's rules before the ultimate
crown event there was speculation about
whether bjergsen would be playing in mr
b's tournament and afterwards there were
some rumors floating around about his
absence which doublelift addressed on
stream any comment on the rumor
riot blocked bjergsen from participating
oh my god dude don't get me started on
that like that is like the one of the
dumbest things i've ever heard and like
that rumor is is basically like it's
basically confirmed right like i heard
from so many people that ryan blocked
bjergsen from participating it was
supposed to be
bjergsen no but like i have i have to
talk about it this is it's so stupid
riot and lcs blocked bjergsen from
playing in this event
he was supposed to be on mr beast's team
this was confirmed by mr beast in the
comments of a more doublelift youtube
video on the subject saying that he was
surprised riot denied bjergsen from
playing now all of this relates to a
riot rule which restricts lcs players
from playing in third party tournaments
it's at riot's discretion but talking
about all of this wasn't what got
doublelift in trouble it was what he
said next lcs is dying like the
viewership is
absolutely
dying it's there's no
there's no denying it everyone knows
everyone can feel it
why would you not let one of if not the
face of the league
play in an event with two of the biggest
creators in the world literally the
biggest creator in the world lcs could
not pay mr bc enough to like
insert one of their players into an
event that is watched by so many kids
doublelift went on to point out that mr
beast arguably the single biggest
content creator on the planet is a
massive league of legends fan he has
tweeted over and over and over again
about how much he loves the game he's
played for over a decade and has said on
multiple occasions that he intends to
own a league of legends team one day now
he could mean an amateur team but even
if he was to pay the 13 million dollar
price tag for an lcs franchise spot he
could probably afford it mr b's main
youtube channel is one of the most
viewed in the world his real life squig
games video from last year is a great
example of his reach after it pulled in
272 million views to date and back in
march this year he shared on linkedin
that he racked up 283
million views in a single month
doublelift is arguing that riot should
consider themselves lucky that not only
is this guy a massive league fan he's
also running these huge tournaments with
millions of eyeballs watching perhaps
some of them have never even seen the
game before to put it bluntly he thinks
riot should be bending over backwards to
help mr beast with his third-party
events even if it means allowing an lcs
player like bjergsen to compete now riot
or some of you guys might disagree with
that but that wasn't what pissed riot
off here it was the fact that doublelift
said the lcs is dying now you might say
so what why should a big independent
streamer like doublelift give to what
riot thinks of him well if you've been
following closely you'll know that riot
gave doublelift co-streaming rights for
the lcs meaning he can broadcast the
games himself with his own commentary
however each co-streamer has to agree to
a set of riot's rules including not
disparaging the lcs and if they break
any of those rules riot can take those
rights away your boy got headshot by lcs
a couple days ago i was talking about
how
lcs was so stupid uh for not letting
bjergsen play the mr beast tournament
and i think i said the words lcs is
dying so your boy got extremely turbo
headshot by lcs
i'm on my second strike my first strike
was just something completely random i
was watching youtube video and like it
said some profanity i insta clicked out
but i got my first check so i got my
second strike which means i can't code
stream this upcoming weekend of lcs okay
and as a token of my apology i wanted to
correct my statement lcs is not dying
and they're not stupid actually the leak
is thriving this is an unedited photo
that i took right here okay as a token
of my apology it is absolutely going
nuts 236k views this of course sparked a
lot of debate within the community about
whether there is any merit to the claim
that the lcs is dying yeah i i saw that
on twitter apparently right and devilish
said league's dying so
riot isn't letting them co-stream oh
[ __ ] oh no you can't go stream
boring ass lcs
nice bro
lcs is two kills at 30 minutes oh that's
really entertaining to watch and
commentate on i feel bad for the casters
currently that's so [ __ ] dead and
like you don't know any of the players
anyway and in a lcs sucks as well not
only does any lcs suck with the game
supporting us right now as well so these
casters are like trying to like thank us
to talk so at like 90 of the game
they're talking about their day
it's actually miserable others out there
were more focused on riot's decision to
suspend doublelift from co-streaming
that weekend even mr beast chipped in to
suggest that the whole thing is simply a
fat l now we could sit here and debate
all day about whether or not the lcs is
dying anecdotally i feel like a lot of
people i know will always tune in for
the big games but might not keep up to
date with every other small game in the
season but i'm just one guy that's a
very small sample size esportscharts.com
show that this year's spring split had a
record low in terms of average viewers
and hours watched but it's difficult to
make judgments based off this we've had
a lot of variables such as the pandemic
the rise of co-streaming and the fact
that there's a lot more games now in a
season now it would take a whole video
here to analyze just exactly what is
going on with lcs viewership also riot
aren't exactly the most open when it
comes to their raw data but i think even
the most staunch lcs defender would have
to agree that something isn't quite as
it used to be last year travis gafford
surveyed
2739 people who said their interest in
watching the lcs had decreased he found
that the common claims of people not
enjoying league or not having an n a
team do well internationally were
actually not the top answers instead
respondents said that a lack of
interesting storylines and players had
turned them off from watching the
broadcast admittedly that wasn't the
biggest sample size but it does perhaps
give an indicator of what's going on
there are interesting storylines going
on the rise of hundred thieves and eg
mirroring the slumps of tsm and cloud9
we've still got veterans like bjergsen
and jensen duking it out while additions
like jodopian and danny have captured
hearts and i even think tsm's new top
laner soul might be added to that list
but for some people out there this just
isn't enough i'd be interested to know
what you guys think are the critics here
just waxing nostalgic for a bygone era
is the lcs just settling down to its
core viewership after almost a decade or
are things worse than ryan is letting on
is the lcs truly dying and if so why
doublelift will likely be back to
co-streaming the lcs this weekend but
already this week his comments were
being memed on by strangers in his games
you're no mercy
oh whoa whoa whoa
there you go you're already here
okay these guys are funny what have i
started guys
oh god
everyone's just gonna start saying lcs
is dying because i talked about my
strike doublelift is currently sitting
on two strikes so i doubt he'll be
saying anything publicly about his
belief that the lcs is dying in the near
future but that doesn't mean the
conversation is over let me know your
thoughts
[Music]
i was going to talk about the fact that
a lot of people seem to think that i am
standing up in my videos
no liz you see me half the time with my
with my black chair in this exact
position no i'm sitting on my little
like bar store it's a spinny bar stool
i'm spinning right now on a bar stool
see
see i you thought the same thing too
well i've dispelled that myth that myth
has been dispelled